Speaker 1: The last 24 hours have seen both the
reports that Trump is imminently going to get
indicted and subsequently arrested by the Justice
Department. Federal charges and the last 24 hours
saw denials from Donald Trump, even when some
of these reports came from Trump's own social
media site. Truth. Social Censure. Let's discuss
a an article on just the news, which is sort of
a wacky right wing website. Feds informed Trump
he is Target likely to be indicted as DOJ Rebuffs
Prosecutorial misconduct claim. Trump Defense has
submitted secret evidence alleging a prosecutor
tried to sway witness testimony by discussing
federal judgeship. Also published two Truth
Social. This message Breaking Feds Informed Trump
of imminent Indictment by Special Counsel Jack
Smith. However, Trump denying the report from his
own website, posting, quote, No one has told me
I'm being indicted and I shouldn't be because I've
done nothing wrong. But I have assumed for a years
that I am a capital T target of the weaponized
DOJ and FBI, starting with the Russia, Russia,
Russia. Hoke The No collusion Mueller report
Impeachment Hoax number one Impeachment Hoax
Number two the perfect Ukraine phone call
and various other scams and witch hunts. A
travesty of justice and election interference
at a level never seen before. Republicans in
Congress must make this their number one issue.
So is it true that Trump is imminently going to
be indicted and arrested federally and charged?
These would be the second charges against Trump.
We may then see additional federal charges. We
may then see charges at the state level out of
Georgia sometime between July and September.
Or is it all wrong? My bottom line on this
is that it does increasingly seem like, yes,
Donald Trump is going to be indicted federally.
However, he may not have been informed of it over
the last 24 to 48 hours. The way that just the
news reported, other reports claimed that maybe
by the end of tomorrow, the DOJ will be requesting
those indictments from the grand jury that has
reconvened. It's just important to remember
when the indictments are asked for to the
grand jury and then when the grand jury votes,
potentially yes, to do the indictments and then
when the indictment actually happens. These are
three different things. And so like with many of
these news events that are quickly taking shape
and changing and whatever the case may be, you
have to remember that sometimes people are just
confused about which step of the process
they're referring to. But at this point,
my guess, my prediction and I'm not in
the prediction game, but my prediction,
if you don't make me bet on it, is that, yes,
Donald Trump is going to be indicted federally.
And it seemed to send him into an absolute
and total panic. Let's talk about that next.